one topic we weren't able to get to
today Chris cuz we just had so many
other things to discuss the suggestion
that jenavian clown ease demands may be
softening by a few million dollars per
year look jenavian clown I don't think
it's about the money I think it's about
the fact that people can't give the guy
a proper physical as long as he wants
anything more than the veteran minimum
they're gonna demand on having the
ability to take a very close look at
where he is physically before making a
commitment to him otherwise you're
potentially throwing away money no doubt
about it and you know also I do think
it's about money a little bit you know
that ties into you know this is a guy
that's been beat up a lot he plays a
really physical brand of football as is
so you got a question you know can his
body hang in there for two three years
in a row to where he can really
contribute to our football team I think
those are all the big questions let
alone - what yes you're saying without
being able to do the medical evaluation
is scary for this type of athlete
especially coming off surgery so I don't
know if he's dropping his price or
whatever it may be but you know we you
and I both know he's one of the kings of
Ethne play up and there's some teams who
seriously have a need for his position
and I and have money to you know just
the name a few you know the Jets the
Houston Texans I look at the Houston
Texans get involved in Jadeveon Clowney
again if it were the right bee subsidies
right it would be something if he'd end
up back in Houston I mean they have the
money to do it and they have a big-time
need at the position but there is a lot
of teams even the Philadelphia Eagles
who I look right now they got enough
money to figure out and wiggle around
and just sign a Jadeveon Clowney they
have the need so I gotta think there's a
market out there I'm just I'm guessing
between what you said and maybe his
asking price was just a little too steep
for some teams to swallow you know it
would take a lot of humble pie being
consumed by both clowny and Bill O'Brien
the coach and GM of the Texans for him
to go back there i that that's a tough
fence to mend up because of the way that
everything ended the quick trade last
year the refusal to sign him to a
long-term deal they never signed into a
long-term deal they squatted on him for
his entire rookie contract and then
traded him
as a franchise tag player and he had to
go to a seattle and play there last year
although hey maybe he should be happy
with the texans they ended up paying a
big chunk of his salary even though
playing for a different team that topic
was inspired by a question from Josh in
Tacoma who wants to know what's Jadeveon
Clowney is real market who does he end
up with give me a guess of who he signs
with and how much he gets I'm gonna
guess it's a you know I'm gonna say the
New York Jets coming to sweep him up at
some point I would think Greg Williams
would love to get his hands on Jadeveon
Clowney and I think the Jets fans are a
little underwhelmed by the lack of
big-name so far in free agency I think
he would be a guy that would certainly
fit the football needs and you know put
them put the fanbase at ease and you
know I think ultimately you know I don't
know what kind of contract he's gonna
get I don't think it's gonna be anything
like five or six years or you know huge
guaranteed money I would think it's a
two or three-year deal where a team can
get out of it you know after one or two
years just in case another serious
injury arises so you know something
around there for an average of you know
I don't know Mike what do you think
sixteen seventeen million dollars a year
I think would probably be about where he
gets and I think the Seahawks are just
waiting for the number to fall to a
range that I think is acceptable the
risk the reward and we've seen the
reward they would not have beaten the
49ers on that monday night last season
if they didn't have Jadeveon Clowney he
delivered that victory and I know that
there were a lot of other hands in the
pot but without him
I don't think they win that game he
sparked them at a time when it felt like
the 49ers were starting to maybe pull
away from the Seahawks the 49ers were
the better team but the Seahawks found a
way to win the game that night and
clowny had a lot to do with it it's
tough you know just because you look at
some of the guys like where clowny is
gonna look at it and go okay you know
guys like D Ford you know Jadeveon
Clowney he's a better all-around
football player at the D Ford and he's
making 17 million dollars a year so I
understand where he's gonna look at that
Olivier Vernon for what he's done for
the Cleveland Browns the last few years
you know it's not Jadeveon Clowney class
so that's where the problem is so maybe
I'm
a little low here maybe he gets a big
chunk of guaranteed money and gets a lot
of big numbers early on in his career
maybe somebody does sign him to a four
or five year deal to lessen the cat blow
throws a lot of guaranteed money at them
and then it's a deal that they can get
out of after two years if possible
something like that actually the more I
talk about this and think about this I
think that's probably the way it'll go
yeah I just I just think that the
Seahawks are biding their time and
they're waiting and waiting and they're
waiting and the fact there's no other
market out there eventually gets him to
dip to a point where they say we have to
have this guy we have to we have to take
this risk and take this guy back onto
our team because he's just too good when
he's healthy
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports